thanks and thanks for the organizers for
asked me to speak so the previous two
talks of today we're about meta
algorithms in some sense and this is
very much a traditional algorithms
question and very old one sort of an
obsession of mine and I should also say
some subset of you have heard version of
this talk before it's similar to the one
that you've seen there's something new
in the middle that I stuck in there that
I hope you'll find interesting so
station for that okay so this is the
problem we're interested in multiplying
n by n matrices I'll sort of draw the
picture this way on many of the slides
so just get used to it here these are n
by n matrices with let's say complex
entries and as we all know takes n cubed
operations to do this in the standard
way stress and discover that you can do
faster than that in 1969 and then set
off this race to try to find the to
determine the exponent of matrix
multiplication Omega the smallest number
real number such that you can do n by n
matrix multiplication in about end to
the Omega operations and so we all know
that you know so in these terms in terms
of Omega the standard algorithm shows
that I make is less than or equal to 3
that's not very exciting stress and show
that it's less than two point eight one
and then there's a whole sequence of
further improvements that some of them
made sort of large improvements in the
last several years there's been a
resurgence of sort of small improvements
over the coppersmith winograd 2.3 75 or
so which had stood for a long time in
Virginia of course was one of those who
is really pushing that forward and in
this talk what I'd like to do is to try
to give you a very quick summary of the
sort of ideas that went into the work
starting from the very beginning leading
up to the present day I certainly won't
do justice to Virginia's work and and
the most recent things but I'll give you
a sense of what was going on there I
hope and then I'd like to spend the
second part of the talk talking about
our approach one that was developed with
a whole list of co-authors that I listed
on the first slide which works I think
in a quite different way by embedding
the problem into semi
simple algebra multiplication there is
interesting group theory in those
connections so see asian schemes and
coherent configurations and i'll try to
give you a sense of what the ideas are
there that's my plan so let me just
start at the very beginning just to sort
of set the stage with one a couple of
slides just point out that this is
really a question about tensor rank
which many of you know so we can talk
about the bilinear a bilinear
computation of complexity m which would
be in the case of matrix multiplication
taking em different products of the form
some linear combination of the entries
of a time some linear combination of the
entries of B and of course dressen's
algorithm fits that framework the
standard at matrix multiplication
algorithm fits very American it's a very
natural way to try to compute a matrix
product because it is a bilinear a
collection of by linear forms after all
okay then you take the result to be
linear combinations of these products so
this is what we would call a bilinear
computation and you would measure its
complexity by the number of
multiplications and as many of you know
when you express things this way the an
exactly equivalent question is what is
the rank of matrix multiplication of the
matrix multiplication tensor I'll say
exactly what the matrix multiplication
tensor is in a moment we label it with
this little notation here but to say
that the rank is that most m is the same
thing as saying that you have a very
bilinear computation of complexity ms
and multiplications now some of you are
probably thinking and sort of a very
natural thing at least for this crowd to
think about when you're asking this
question is do we really need to be
doing bilinear computations to solve
this problem I mean this is an
arithmetic problem we should think about
arithmetic circuits maybe there's weird
cancellations why should I only do
quadratic computations and so on right
and the nice thing about this particular
problem is that stress and showed a long
time ago that you can assume that it's
bilinear without loss of generality in
other words if you define Omega to be
what you and I what many people in this
audience might consider to be a natural
measure which is the smallest exponent
such that you have an arithmetic circuit
that computes n by n matrix
multiplication in about n to the Omega
time that's the same number as you get
if you consider only
by linear computations of this form or
equivalently the rank of the matrix
multiplication tensor and that's the
reason why i think it's become a very
appealing problem from a mathematical
perspective because we're really asking
a question about tensor rank without
loss of generality ok so I just did that
to sort of set the stage and to sort of
excuse why we are always talking about
tensors it really is without loss of
generality of court so now tensors for
the purpose of this talk a 3d array of
complex numbers and I'll draw it this
way on many of the slides of course you
can have more than three dimensions
tensors and so on but that's what's
relevant for the discussion about matrix
multiplication and what is the rank 1
tensor as you all know it's a tensor
which has its I JK entry the product of
an X i YJ and ZK given three vectors x y
and z and if you would like to label the
cube that way that somehow a good way to
think of it that's a rank 1 tensor and a
rank R tensor is a tensor which is can
be expressed as the sum of our rank 1 10
stress of course and a useful
perspective that when we're thinking
about things on the future good some
some of the upcoming slides is to an
equivalent notion for what it means to
be a rank R tensor is that if you take
the slices that is a few sort of orient
things and then take the matrices that
you get by slicing going back into the
board then the all of the slices of a
rank are tensor can be written as a
linear combination of our different Rank
1 matrices
to be the same maybe Cisco or you pick
you find our rank one matrix ease and
then you say i can write all of the
slices of which there will be many more
than our of them as linear combinations
of those rank one
okay so what is the matrix
multiplication tensor it's worth
actually writing it down and looking at
it because it's a very symmetric very
beautiful and very concrete thing to
work with its in so we label it with
this notation angle bracket nnn to
indicate that you're doing n by N by n
by n matrix multiplication it's an N
squared by N squared by N squared tensor
sometimes we write a tensor by
expressing it by a try linear form in
which we have formal variables XY and Z
and the coefficient on a given X I Y Jay
Z K is the coefficient that occurs in I
JK position and in this case the one
thing that sometimes you have to make a
little switch in your mind it's natural
to index the X is Y's and Z's from the
matrix multiplication tensor by pairs of
indices that range between 0 and m or 1
and n does this trailer near form and I
draw drew the picture for the two-by-two
case because i think it's just at least
from my way of thinking it's easy
easiest to think of these things in
concrete terms so here's a 2 by 2 matrix
multiplication problem here is the
associated four by four by four tensor
and I wrote it out as the four different
slices each of which is a four by four
matrix and if you associate the rows
with the entries of the a matrix and the
columns with these entries of the B
matrix as I've done in that first
picture you can actually see that the
pattern of ones in each of the slices
describes the bilinear form which is
each of the target result matrix entries
that is to say the c11 entry is you know
a 11 x b 11 + 8 12 x be 21 and that's
captured by the coefficient one here on
the a11 and be one 1 entry and the one
here on the a12 and ab21 entry and in
general any bilinear form you can keep
track of this way and each of the slices
goes through and gives you the different
by linear forms that occur in the four
entries of the result matrix
so you can see there's this little
pattern we're the ones occur in
corresponding positions and then they
sort of march through the cube or the
square that as I sort of tried to
highlight with the blue okay major
complication tensor where keep in mind
okay in general of course if we write n
MP we mean the matrix multiplication
sensor associated with and by M matrix
multiplication by N by M by M by P
matrix multiplication it's a tensor with
these dimensions it's again got the same
trend linear form and then if you draw
the picture you'll see that the slices
of which there are n times P of them
each have this have em different
rectangles sort of organized diagonally
like this and then the one marches
across the different positions in the
different slices of course funny way so
we're just trying to find the rank of
this family fencers now we'd like to
show that it's close to N squared
unfortunately that's a much harder thing
to do and then just finding the rank of
a matrix of course and in fact in
general hard thing for this particular
way so let me tell you the stratus
source described the strategies over the
years for upper bounding the rank of the
matrix multiplication tensor let's start
with a very simple first one which is
that if you take the I tensor power of
the N by n matrix multiplication tensor
then that's the same thing as the end to
the I by N to the I matrix
multiplication tensor ok this is
analogous to the observation that we all
know that if you take a large and end to
the I by N to the I matrix
multiplication problem and block it into
n by n matrix multiplication then you
have a fast way of doing n by n matrix
multiplication then you can get a fast
way for doing the large one in terms of
the rank it's this expression here the
rank event the I matrix multiplication
is at most the rank of n by n matrix
multiplication raised to the eye and so
a strategy that this suggests is you
should just find the rank for some small
n by hand and of course this is what
Strassen did when he found that two by
two matrix multiplication can be done
with seven multiplications instead of
eight and get that yields a pound of
Omega is less than two point eight one
so then you say well that's a great
strategy let's work on three by three
and
for three by three we actually don't
know the answer it's somewhere between
we have a lower bound of 19 we have an
upper bound of 23 unfortunately that
already gives a worse bound then the
2.81 and at this point it's worth
pointing out another national question
is well by now shouldn't we be able to
do computer searches and the computer
search without further information or
symmetries or cleverness is really
infeasible if you think about a three by
three case for example then you have a
nine by nine ten sir and you have 9 x 9
x 9 10 sir and even if you're looking
for 01 decompositions of an into slow
rank tensors is sort of a prohibitively
large search space now to say that you
couldn't do something clever but this
seems to be where things are stuck in
this weight
now a really important advance came with
this notion of border rank so you can
talk about the rank of a sequence of
attend sirs that approach the target
tensor entry wise okay instead of the
rank just the rank ordinary rank of a
tensor and it's actually can be smaller
than the ordinary rank here is the sort
of very simple example so if you take if
you forget this epsilon for a moment and
you look at this two by two by two
tensor whose two slices are represented
here you can show that it has ranked
three okay that's not hard to do if you
allow an epsilon here where epsilon is
going to 0 that's a sequence of tensors
that approaches that target tensor and
that has rank when your allotted epsilon
has ranked 2 because you this is a rank
1 tensor here if you think about it and
this is a rank 1 tensor and you can take
a linear combination of these two get
these two slices this this is in fact
the first slice and if you take this
slice you know up minus epsilon inverse
times this slice I guess you get the
second slice so it has border rank 2 so
there's a separation and you can search
for abort and by n matrix multiplication
algorithms with small border rank and
the reason this is ben officials there's
this amazing theorem that shows that if
you can prove that the border rank is
less than R then you get a bound on
Omega which is basically the same that's
exactly the same in fact is what you
would get if you proved an ordinary
bound on the rank of our okay so finding
border rank bounces just as good as
finding bounds on the ordinary rank of
matrix multiplication it's in it yes so
when I say Omega is less than this I
mean omega which is defined of course
for a growing in and indeed it's the
same n on the left and the right but the
actual matrix multiplication instance
for which you will realize this improved
bound based on the border rank of course
is large because you have to do
something there's some machinery
involved a very simple machinery but
someone
and there and this already led to an
improvement so beanie I believe it out
in the late 70s showed that the border
rank of two by two by two by three
matrix multiplication is at most 10 and
if you plug that in you get there to
make us less than 2.79 is a little
better than stressin in fact this idea
of border rank played a role in a lot of
the future maybe all the future sort of
improvements in the sequence I'm
starting the stressn then I'm trying to
summarize now very quickly the other
really important observation or sort of
generalization of the game came with
this notion of direct sum of tensors so
in other strategy is that you can try to
think about independent matrix
multiplications so you can think about
doing an n-by-n matrix multiplication
and an M by M matrix multiplication in
parallel at once so that is to say you
take linear combinations of all of the
entries of the two input matrices the N
by N and an buy em the linear
combinations of the other two matrices
you do some combination of them take
some combination the mobile occations
take combination the result and get all
the answers to the two instances at once
so it's like matrix multiplication in
parallel so strategy three is to bound
the now we're allowed to say board a
rank of the direct sum of small matrix
multiplication tensors can you do lots
of independent matrix multiplications in
better than the sort of trivial way and
there's this wonderful theorem called
the asymptotic some inequality of which
I've written just a special case here
which says that if you can do if you get
a bound on the rank of lots of
independent matrix multiplications then
you get this kind of inequality that n
the sum of n is to the Omega is less
than R if you had a single matrix
multiplication you would get this kind
of inequality and that leads to that log
base end of our bound on the exponent
here you get to sum them together and
that gives you an improvement
potentially because the left hand side
is larger size of these pieces that you
don't say by doing there in terms that
it passes I don't know if you can
improve no I think you're reading it
maybe if it
takes our products in sizes it means
that it means that you could have just
spent the complexity you could have just
done everything separately no it doesn't
say that in fact also we'll see an
example in which the are that you
achieve here is better than what you
would get for each of these separately
and then summon them together and that
improvement is exactly what this what
you'll do better result here than doing
each of the separate things and seeing
what the best one of those would get the
bound which would be for me each one of
those separately let me show you the
example and then ask the question by
convexity the best one individual one of
those would be good as good of a bound
on Omega as you would have had by doing
them all together but if you can save
more than the sum by doing them all
together then you get a better bound ask
it again if it's not clear after the
example so this is the asymptotic some
inequality proved by Sean haga in the
80s and the example which led to
actually quite a big improvement as this
one so the border rank of doing you have
to sort of D decode these expressions
here so this is the four by three four
by three outer product together with a
inner product of vectors of length six
so doing those two things together cost
you only thirteen multiplications now
the way to just sort of a preciate why
this is a significant is that if you
were doing just this the outer product
of a four lengths for vector by our
length three vector that cost you twelve
multiplications there's no other way to
do that that's a lower bound so for one
extra multiplication if you'd like to
think of things that way you get to do
an inner product of line six how about
combining these things together gives
you an improvement and that's by
plugging into theorem gives an Omega
bound on Omega of 2.55
so this is the direct sum of tensors and
then we move to strategy for which is
called the laser method so on well named
a method mainly because it sounds really
impressive so this is also due to stress
and so this isn't it now gets to the
point where I'm not going to be able to
give you it all of a complete account of
this but it's the ideas to look at
tensors that are not matrix
multiplication tensors at all or direct
sums of them but tensors that have the
core structure of matrix multiplication
and whose fine structure components are
each multiplication matrix
multiplication tensors but not
necessarily in a compatible way if you
have something like that then there's a
mechanism by which you can find many
independent matrix multiplications by
looking at a high temps or power and
I'll show you the example which actually
leads to the improvement it's actually
again something that you can really
write down on the slide and look at in a
very concrete way so this is these are
the slices there are q + 1 slices sorry
q slices there q x 1 x cube by one and
you can see there's a 1 in corresponding
corners and then the one sort of marches
in corresponding positions along the top
and up the side so that gives you the
cue different slices so that is a tensor
it happens to have the same here bored
of rank q plus 1 but and it has a the
course structure of a 1 by 2 by 1 matrix
multiplication which looks a little bit
like this you can sort of see how the
pink regions have that form and the fine
structure looks like a scalar times a
row vector for this one and a row column
vector times a scalar for this one the
details of that are sort of sort of
extracting that from the picture not so
important except to point out that this
has this kind of feature that we were
describing like I said the border rank
of this can be shown to be Q plus 1
again something can sit down by hand
them and work out I mean you optimize
and find that Q equals 25 is best for
once you plug it through the machine or
in this yields a bound on Omega of 2.48
laser method
and then coppersmith winograd and beyond
and with apologies to Virginia and the
other authors who worked on this I'm
going to do this in sort of a quick way
coppersmith winograd and beyond so they
looked at the border rank of a tensor
which can be expressed I'm no longer
drawing it but it's written in this
trial in your form here there's sort of
six sort of pieces of this tensor if you
will it has a parameter Q just like the
stress and tensor head and this tensor
has border rank q plus two that's not
significant or exciting in any way
except once you realize that there's
sort of machinery that you can layer on
top of this which allows you to take
again giant tensor powers and find in
those large sensor powers many
independent small matrix multiplications
now at this point you actually have a
choice you can sort of choose in this
high tensor power what are the
proportions you're shooting for for the
different sort of groups of coefficients
and choosing those target proportions it
influences both the size of the
independent matrix multiplications that
occur and how many of them and you have
to balance this and if you do that in
optimized for Q you get that with Q
equal to 6 you get a bound on Omega
which is two point three eight which is
a little bit better than the previous
one and then these things I just usually
the best thing it we please say a factor
of six on the number of multiplications
no factor of six on the number of
multiplications when the number of
multiplications is enormous is
imperceptible and the exponent so that's
probably an indication that at this
level of describing things that look it
not able to sort of explain the
machinery and how the how that choice of
target proportions affects things
but so this is a cub so this is the
tensor which gave rise to so coppersmith
winning ground and Beyond again this is
I guess second slide of this analyzed
tensor powers of this tensor so you get
a nice bound by looking at just this
tensor then you can look at the square
of this tensor it has six squared pieces
if you adopt my sort of shorthand wavy
notation and you separately optimize the
proportions of all of those and you get
the bound which stood for some number 20
years or so of 2.3 75 of copper Smith &
Winograd and then if you look at the
fourth tensor power something that
people only took up in the recent last
several years it turns out you can do a
little bit better and you and then if
you analyze the eighth power you can do
a little bit better and the 16th power a
little bit better and a little bit
better and as you can see the number of
pieces gets to be enormous you have to
use a computer search to do this I'm
brushing under the rug lots of
innovation sort of cleverness in the way
that you do the computer search and the
way that you choose use symmetries and
sort of build on each successive one to
construct the pre the next proportions
and so on so there's the sequence of
improvements and then there's a paper by
and Venus illness and leg all which
showed that the end tensor power of this
can't beat some number which i hope i've
gotten right but it's something that's
there's still some room for improvement
but it won't go all the way to 20 k
which I think confirmed many of you
extrapolate from these numbers it feels
like there's diminishing returns and so
like I said I'm giving short trip to
this and if bridging you were to give
the talk I think there's some ways that
she's thinking of and other people I
think maybe that might get around this
barrier so it remains to be seen yeah
there's way I mean it relies on some
specific features of the way this tensor
works so maybe it's not the end of the
line for that approach but i would like
to advocate or at least tell you about a
different approach and one that I feel
gets a little bit beyond some of the
limitations of the sequence that I've
to describe so so far the strategy has
been to bound the border rank of some
small tensor by hand and then use some
machinery to build get an asymptotic
bound from high tensor powers and the
machinery is potentially very
sophisticated but in the end you start
with some fixed finite 10 so that you
can write down you know it's six by six
by five or something like that and you
write down on a piece of paper and you
find a bound on the border rank which is
non-trivial decomposition that's
non-trivial and you work from there so a
disadvantage is that there's sort of a
limited universe of starting tensors is
the matrix multiplication tensors as
direct sums of them there's the straße
intenser there's the coppersmith
winograd tensor and they all have ways
in which they work nicely with the
machinery but somehow there's always
this like starting point that you have
to start with and we don't have many
good candidates for what that could be
and the high tensor powers are hard to
analyze an approach that we've been
developing for a while now has to do
with embedding matrix multiplication
into groups or semi simple algebra is
more care more appropriately and in this
way you don't have to think about doing
anything by hand with look the little
tensors you have to think about a
reduction in the sense of a computer
science reduction that we're used to and
you get to ask questions that are group
theoretic questions and questions about
coherent configurations and Association
schemes that don't seem to necessarily
have connection to matrix multiplication
they're asymptotic questions which were
more familiar with dealing with and you
don't have to have this sort of
connection to tensors okay so let me try
to describe what the idea is so we'd
like so the idea is to try to embed or
reduce n by n matrix multiplication into
semi simple algebra multiplication now
what is semi simple algebra
multiplication for the purpose of this
talk and this is only slightly
simplification it's multiplication which
is isomorphic to block diagonal matrix
multiplication that is in this object
which is in algebra when you multiply
two elements that's isomorphic to after
a big change of basis multiplying block
diagonal matrices where the blocks have
different sizes depending on the
representation theory of the algebra now
at the very sort of general level the
idea is that this al
which I will give you an example of in a
minute should have a nice basis with
some combinatorial structure or some
group theoretic structure or some sort
of meaning where we can pose the
question of whether you can embed matrix
multiplication into this algebra by
asking a question that's combinatorial
in nature or group theoretic in nature
and then we sell that problem we hope
and use this isomorphism or the
structure of the algebra to conclude
that we've reduced n by n matrix
multiplication to a bunch of smaller
matrix multiplications these block size
matrix multiplications and then recurse
okay so this is a very high level
description of the strategy I'll just
remark on this slide that if the algebra
is commutative then this these block
diagonal matrices are all one by one so
it's just diagonal matrix multiplication
and there's no real recursion it just
reduces to a bunch of multiplications in
the sense that we thought of back in
some of us started back in nineteen
sixty-nine stressin sense so let me give
you an example of an algebra by talking
by talking about groups and this was
really actually something that we're
still thinking about and was subject of
a couple of papers and we have
conjectures having to do with it and so
on but let me give you the idea here and
one proof so if we're given a finite
group then the group algebra C of G is
just formal linear combinations of group
elements these a sub G's or complex
numbers okay you can add those as form a
linear combinations and you can multiply
them in the natural way that is to say
you sort of do this term wise and the
complex numbers multiply as complex
numbers in group elements G and H there
multiply according to the group
multiplication law after you simplify
things you see that the multiplication
is some kind of convolution that depends
on the structure of the group now the
structure of a group algebra is it's a
semi simple algebra that is to say it's
like some more fit to a bunch of matrix
algebra is whose sizes whose dimensions
are D 1 up to DK and those are the
character degrees of the group were the
dimensions of the irreducible
representations of the group and there's
a whole theory that helps you understand
what those are as once you know what the
group is which I won't go into but this
is the feature that allows this to give
you a reduction in the group elements in
this case
the nice basis as I was trying to
describe in the general framework and
what do I mean by that I mean this that
if you are asking about reducing n by n
matrix multiplication to group algebra
multiplication you can do it by asking
for three subsets subgroups of the group
x y&z that satisfy what a cult what's
called the triple product property that
is to say if you take the product of a
little x x little while x a little Z and
get one you want that to happen only in
the trivial way only if x y and z Ro
themselves 1s sets x sub sub groups x
y&z of g satisfy the triple product
property if whenever you have this
little triple product being one it
happens only when all of the elements of
themselves are one and it turns out
first of all it turns out that you have
to but you can generalize this to
subsets and then talk about the quotient
sets of x y and z but i encourage you to
ignore that detail for the moment it
turns out that if you have that feet
those three sub sets of the group then
there's a very natural way to perform
matrix multiplication inside the group
algebra that is you take the XY entry of
the a matrix and take it as the
coefficient on X Y inverse sum of all of
those you take the sum of the YZ entries
of the B matrix or the say that Y is the
entry the B matrix is the coefficient on
Y Z inverse and then you multiply these
two group algebra elements together and
the claim is that you can find the XZ
entry of the result matrix as the
coefficient on x z inverse in the
product ok and that there's a you don't
have to pay attention to this but the
proof is the sort of the one line you
just sort of work out what the
multiplication is but this is the what I
mean by a nice basis so we're trying to
embed into group algebra multiplication
on its face that's just saying well
let's see if we can transform the from
and one into the other but the embedding
actually is captured by something which
is really a group theory question or one
where you really feel like you can maybe
use idea about groups
and then use the machinery of doing
multiplication group outro
multiplication via the isomorphism to
block diagonal matrix multiplications
actually get something out of this okay
so what does this actually mean in terms
of the number of multiplications suppose
you actually can do this so embedding as
I've just described plus the structure
of the group algebra as a semi simple
algebra yields a bound on the rank or
the number of multiplications and what
is that well it's ultimately you do n by
n matrix multiplication by embedding it
into this block diagonal matrix
multiplication and you may remember that
the for the group algebra the size of
the blocks are these D eyes which are
the character degrees of the group and
so you can say well how many
multiplications is that so I have to do
all these di bi di matrix
multiplications so if I just use the
trivial n cubed matrix multiplication
algorithm then you use this number of
multiplications write the sum of the DI
cubed but some of you are already
sitting there saying of course that's
not what you should do you should use
better than the trivial we already know
how to do that and so in fact what we
should do is do what ever the best
algorithm is recursively and so the real
number that you use is the sum of the D
eyes to the Omega but before we sort of
go down that road I've just point out
that Omega is at least two and so we use
at least the sum of the DI squared
multiplications and some of the DI
Squared's is the same as the size of the
group because of the sizing morphism and
so a challenge that's actually are worth
while it was our way of approaching this
is just can you tell me if you can embed
K by K matrix multiplication into a
group of size about K squared because if
you can't you don't get it you don't
have a shot at getting exponent 2 from
this approach right now I'm going to try
to do K by K matrix multiplication in
much better than K cubed hopefully close
to K squared multiplications since i
need at least the size of the group many
multiplications i better hope to be able
to do this in a group down a size about
k squared ok
why aren't you done because it depends
i'll show you the actual theorem in a
minute but the problem is is that the
group may be small but this di the DI s
may be large and because the actual sort
of number that uses di to the Omega for
example if one of the de Guise is larger
than the end that you started with
you've reduced n by n matrix
multiplication to a bunch of major
complications one of which is larger and
you're not making any progress so you
need the small small representations so
there's a challenge I want one that you
can think about and you can show that an
abelian group requires size K cubed so
you have to use mount abelian groups
simple argument I'm and in fact we can
do this we can show this is what way
back in the early papers in 2003 I guess
we can embed K by K matrix
multiplication into a symmetric group
that has size about K squared and I'll
show you the embedding because actually
the new something that's a little bit
new a few weeks old I wanted to mention
as a question actually about this
particular construction so here's a way
to think of this embedding it's actually
kind of pretty so we have n objects
which I've arranged in a triangular
array like this and SN acts on those by
permuting them so the permutations
forgive these n elements and we need to
find three subgroups which have size
about the square root and I claim that
these three subgroups satisfy that so
this is subgroup X it's those
permutations of these n elements that
preserve things within the red boxes ok
and then the next subgroup is you can
probably guess preserve those boxes and
the next subgroup reserves those so
that's three subgroups of the group and
you have to trust me when I say tell you
that those three subgroups actually if
you work out sterling approximation and
so on half-size about the square root of
the size of the group ok but I Neil need
to convince you that they satisfy the
triple product property so what does
that mean it means that if you first
permute things let's say inside the blue
boxes and then permute things inside the
green boxes and then premier things
inside the red boxes and everything ends
up where it started you have to tell you
I have to prove to you that none of
those three permutations moved anything
anywhere they were all the identity
let me do that so i turned the triangle
on its side so that we can talk about
rows columns and diagonals okay and let
me prove that by looking at one point at
a time so let's look at what happens to
this little corner here so first thing
that happens is it gets moved somewhere
in its row so imagine it moving around
and then wherever it ends up in along
that row it then gets moved up and down
in its column by the column permutation
right but it's supposed to get back to
where it started by a final diagonal
permutation and the diagonal permutation
fixes this point so you have to get back
inside this box okay I think you can see
from the picture that you can't have
moved it all to the right or it all up
if you end up back here so this point is
fixed by all three permutations let me
think about this one and the key thing
now is that this one the left to the
point to its left is fixed so it can't
move left it has to move in its row
permutation has to move somewhere to the
right and then up and down in the column
and then it has to get back inside this
box to have a chance of getting back to
where it started and I think you can see
again from the picture you can to move
it all to the right and it all up if
you're going to get back to the box and
so that one's fixed and in the same way
that's fixed that's fixed that's fixed
and then once the whole rows fixed you
just start repeating it for the next row
in the next row and then they're all
fixed which is what we wanted to try to
show the triangle construction now
here's the act so there's the theorem
and the unfortunate thing is that this
relates to ball is this question this
doesn't give you a good bound on the
exponent of matrix multitude of you any
bound at all unfortunately because the
largest character degree for the
symmetric group is unfortunately quite
large it's in fact even larger than the
size of one of these subgroups and so
the reduction is sort of meaningless
unfortunate here's the actual theorem
which I think maybe some of you have
been wondering about so it says if you
can in a group that has supports K by K
matrix multiplication with character
degrees d1 d2 d3 etc the actual bound on
Omega you get is what's implied by this
inequality which is a very natural one
it says well the number of
multiplications that are required to do
K by K matrix multiplication that's
Kate's the Omega is upper bounded
well you were just did a reduction so
it's the number of multiplications
required to do the D by D the D I
blocked matrix multiplication some of
the eyes you can see there that if the D
is our large relative decade then you
don't get any kind of about so here's
one way to sort of sort of get more of a
handle on which you should be aiming for
you want x y&z that's a subgroup subsets
of the group that satisfy the triple
product property and K the size of the
matrix multiplication instance that they
support which is if you want to be very
careful the geometric mean of the x y&z
should be approaching the size of the
group square root of the size of the
group that was our goal that we stated
before right okay and you would like
that the maximum character degree is
bounded away from the size of the group
square root of the size of the group by
a constant than the exponent now the
largest that Deacon d-max can ever be is
the square root of the size of the group
so you're asking just because the sum of
the DI Squared's is equal to the size
the group you're asking for a little bit
better than that if you can do that
simultaneously with having this very
good embedding like the one that we just
did for this metric group then you get
actually omega is equal to 2 ok so I'm
of course deliberately presenting it in
a way that makes it seem like it's right
around the corner that seems to be a
hard thing to get those combination of
things but that's some way of
understanding what you should be
shooting for and then there's the
here's the thing that's actually we sort
of just noticed a few weeks ago so this
symmetric group this triangle
construction I told you it's worthless
because the largest character degree is
larger than the size of the subgroup
that I just described but it turns out
that the shape of a triangle is not the
best one so here's a picture of the
triangle of the 30s with n equal to 36
so the size of the group is 36 factorial
the size of each of the three subgroups
is you know they're you know 1 factorial
times 2 factorial times 3 factorial
etcetera up to 8 factorial ok and just
to keep track of things I computed the
log of the size of the group it's a
large number and it's whatever it is
some number if you take the triangle
make it a little rounder then you get
subgroups who has sighs you know three
factorial 4 times 4 factorial times 5
factorial etc like that and that number
that log but subgroup is a little bit
larger so actually it's possible at the
moment that by choosing the shape to be
different than a triangle and in some
weight the best possible shape that you
can actually push the size of these
subgroups to be so they're all
approaching the square root of the size
of the group but they may actually
approach to the square root of the size
the group fast enough that they overtake
the largest character degree and in fact
this construction potentially could give
you X 1 into as a question we're
thinking about now but it's sort of a
funny the triangle construction is
always a nice proof than see on the
slide and you can all understand it and
then the question is well find the best
shape it's not a triangle actually this
doesn't give you anything it this is so
we're talking about the rate at which we
approach the square root of size the
group and one of the right one of them
has to approach the square root of size
of the group faster than the other so
it's only going to give it sort of how I
say this once one approaches faster than
the other then you get exponent too and
before that you get nothing so it's a
it's all or nothing it's a tall order
but it's nonetheless something that I
guess we don't really know the fully
Institute they all do which shapes
satisfy the you have to actually meant
eyes how that proof works and it it
turns out that you can do that and
you're sort of really looking for a
surface then you slice it by the x y&z
axes and then it really is becomes a
question about shape I'll just say that
like an even simpler question is can you
find two subgroups whose intersection is
only the identity there are young
subgroups of the symmetric group that is
to say they're just given by these
partitions that are where the partitions
are transverse to each other which is
what you need for the intersection to be
the identity such that their size is
large enough that it would yield this
kind of a result in we don't know the
answer to that
okay so that I wanted to just mention
because I think it's kind of a cool
question to think about let me just sort
of summarize where things can go from
there and maybe I'll go five minutes
over that's okay cheer so so in other
groups that are reached product groups
we've gotten bounds that are not better
than the best known bounds but are
significant nice sounds key part of each
of those constructions is combinatorial
each of those combinatorial
constructions comes with an Associated
conjecture which seems at least to us to
be pretty natural which would imply
omega is equal to I'm not going to talk
about those conjectures amount of time
the disadvantages are that non-trivial
results in this setting require non
abelian groups as I mentioned very
briefly at the beginning and it seems
from our experience that most of the
ideas that you have are foiled by large
character degrees so you get a nice
construction then you go look at the
representation theory of the group and
it turns out to be to the character user
too large so the tension between those
two quantities so this generalization
that we've been thinking about most
recently gets around that and I'll just
say enough of the generalization to sort
of give you a sense of why it can get
around that so I started out by saying
all this is a proach about the embedding
into semi simple algebra so let's just
think very quickly about what that means
in general so general algebra is
specified by a basis this is the one
that I hope will be nice and the quote
and structure constants that tell you
when you multiply basis element a I
times AJ it's a linear combination of
the other basis elements and these
lambda I jk's give you those described
the algebra completely okay so here's a
little picture of the structural tensor
of algebra multiplication it turns out
that it's just populated with those
limbs I jks if you think about it and
asking whether you can realize matrix
multiplication or embed matrix
multiplication or reduce matrix
multiplication to this multiplication
algorithm multiplication is a question
of whether the matrix multiplication
tensor can be found inside there like
you literally can find a piece of this
sub cube of this cube which contains the
matrix multiplication tensor and I put
an asterisk here because contains isn't
quite what you think it means the matrix
multiplication tensor we know and we've
looked at before when you embed it in
in algebra you get a bound on the rank
of a tensor which has these lambda I
jk's input instead of just zeros and
ones with lambda I jk's are not zero the
group algebra turns out that those
structure contents are always 0 or 1 but
in general we may have an embedding in
which you get a realize a tensor which
has non zero and one cove non one
coefficients here and this is some kind
of weighted form of matrix
multiplication but not one that you can
distant on weight by just rescaling the
entries let me give you just a very
quick description of what happens so we
can define the S rank of a tensor to be
the minimum rank of a tensor with the
same support as that a tensor and the
question now becomes does it bound on
the S rank of matrix multiplication tens
tens are implying upper bound on the
ordinary rank because the bound on the S
rank seems to be what comes out of this
more general setting and here just to
make a concrete here's the two-by-two
matrix multiplication that we know and
love here are the results and and we
know how to do this I guess with seven
multiplications things distressin so
here's a question if i had a way of
computing this these four result entries
but there was a two instead in place of
this one product ok if i could do that
in six let's say does that give you
anything does that turn into any kind of
multiplication algorithm for matrix
multiplication so you can't get rid of
this to buy just rescaling the a matrix
because if you rescale that entry then
you mess up this one when you can't get
it by rescaling the b matrix because
that would mess up some other there's no
simple answer to that question we can
even define the S rank version of the
matrix multiplication exponent and the
theorem that we proved in the 2012 paper
is that in fact you can get a bound on
Omega from a bound on the Omega sub s
that is a bount exponents describing the
best rank of a tensor with the same
support it has a little linear
transformation the key thing to notice
is that when Omega sub s approaches to
then Omega approaches to so if you get
exponent 2 for the support rank notion
then you get exponent 24
so this really justifies our ability
that allows us to think about trying to
embed into general semi simple algebra
now coherent configurations and
Association schemes are sometimes called
group theory without groups I'm out of
time so I'm not going to go into the
whole description of them except to say
that they capture lots of neat objects
in algebraic combinatorics that are more
general than groups you can express
something like the triple product
property for these guys and talk about
embedding matrix multiplication into
them and let me just get to the let me
just sort of skip to the algebra
associated with them it's called the
adjacency algebra let me skip to the
punch line which is this so in the case
of groups non-commutative groups were
necessary and that really was hard to
work with because we kept having to deal
with large carried Ruby's we had to
understand representation theory and all
these kinds of things so we needed to
get an embedding into a small group and
have small character degrees at the same
time and those were two goals that
seemed in tension with one another what
we can show in the coherent
configuration framework is the
commutative algebra suffice we have
constructions that are based on the old
constructions that prove that you can
realize non-trivial bounds on Omega in
commutative a very simple varieties of
coherent configurations which I didn't
get a chance to tell you what they are
and the conjectures that from the old
setting if true would imply Omega sub s
is equal to 2 even in this commutative
coherent configuration setting so the
punch line is that you can and should
try to embed n by n matrix
multiplication into a commutative
coherent configuration jet is an object
that generalizes groups of rank about n
squared and if you can do that if you
can do the analog of that triangle
construction I showed you at the
beginning then you're done there's no
further discussion of representation
theory and here my open problem so find
the best shape in place of the triangle
a crazy question that we didn't realize
was even open until recently find a
construction in the new framework that
proves some non-trivial bound on Omega
that's not based on construction the old
setting one of the frustrating things
about what we currently know about the
coherent configurations still seems to
rely on the stuff
with groups is the border rank border s
rank for example of two by two matrix of
implication six instead of seven a
question we don't know the answer to or
find an example where border s rank
really helps you with a matrix
multiplication tensor and in general can
you do this reduction of matrix
multiplication into commutative coherent
configurations which have rank about N
squared and if you do that you get omega
equal to 2x I'm sorry for going over
some people claim that some of these
conjectures are in conflict with some
other conjectures yes right so we have a
paper that yeah so the paper called the
sunflowers in matrix multiplication with
no villain and the musical so the there
are two main conjectures that I didn't
describe in detail that are sort of
combinatorial nature one of them
contradicts a non-standard version of
the of sunflower conjecture one where I
think it's a sort of multicolored
version of this cap set conjecture in
XIII which many people know and and like
in our community that conjecture it sort
of like if you ask people is like 5050
with whether they think it's true or not
and then the non standard version of it
is even less likely to be true but it is
a warning sign that perhaps that
conjecture is not the other that the
combinatorial conjecture may not be true
so that's the connection the other
comment all conjecture as far as we know
is unrelated to sunflowers
so the actually two questions the one is
that you talked about the build
ourselves and the house can be split up
by looking for symmetry the closet
solution some of the other solution have
symmetry so these are imposing the
symmetry condition on there is no sin go
on your course from the copa de vara
airport exit I mean it's just thought
you would like there's similar
symmetries everywhere of course because
we're talking about groups and and
people have actually really proved
things about yeah about that I don't
know of a way in which that
significantly impacts the speed of a
computer search we actually spent a fair
amount of time noticing that some of the
low rank compositions can be found as a
single orbit of some group action and so
that if that were really true if we
could have proved that then that would
speed up the search but we don't know I
think we found the exact count ample so
that right so I mean this is a wide open
question and I don't know of a concrete
answer where it either helped or whether
we can prove a lower bound but we
thought about it another people I've the
other question I was serious about these
done we are looking we have to design a
sub temple they are looking for me now
upper bound on tonight oh really not yes
multiplication one we don't know where
our ocean we do know it's early enough
for their all that I just other example
in our composite are sort of interesting
by the job that are substantially
different I think you know a lot of the
interesting examples come from algebra
multiplication where it really is a
question about matrix multiplication you
know that there's a okay this is not a
quite an answer your question but
there's this far-reaching stressing
conjecture that that perhaps an upper
bound on the asymptotic rank of any
three-dimensional tensor is actually
linear just the side length the largest
sideling the asymptotic rank so when you
take large not synthetic powers so
that's something we don't even know how
to refute that and if that were true of
course the metro station exponent would
be too and everything would be a sin
as possible in this to me conjecture is
that if you take an end let's just say
an N by N by n tensor any tensor the
soil matrix multiplication and ask about
the asymptotic rank so as you take
tensor powers of it does it's what is
its rank you know our to the number of
power the capital n let's say if they
can't answer power then the conjecture
is that or maybe actually just n for all
n by n tensors in other words the
structure that you start of the starting
sensory is irrelevant once you look at a
large asymptotic power it's just
dictated by the size so in this chemical
industry could seem to defeat sports
like a random things that would be a
counter example but you have to prove
it's hard because you have to prove a
lower bound intend to rank for some
large 10 to power maybe and so yeah do
people really really super folks like it
struttin I think made this conjecture
and then I probably if you ask him he
says he's not sure that it is really
true and I think even wrote that in the
margin of one of his papers maybe I'm
confusing it with another story but I
don't know it's out
the defense depends when you ask but now
it may be legen they seem selected and
maybe trying to analyze the random tens
of one way or the other the bungalow
bond yo angry yeah oh the asymptotic
rank is N and so for you by google you
can try for two by two sure but if you
prove enough found on the asymptotic
rank of two by two major formal occasion
you're proving a bound on matrix
multiply wasn't yeah nobody knows no se
thanks again